If you've ever wondered how superheroes manage
to do all that heroic stuff while wearing
those wildly impractical costumes, you're
not alone.
In fact, some of the actors playing these
heroes on the big screen had major issues
with their outfits.
Here's a look at some actors who despised
their superhero costumes.
Jennifer Lawrence
That blue body paint that Jennifer Lawrence
wears in the X-Men films may look cool, but
J-Law herself isn't a huge fan considering
it took a whopping seven hours to apply when
she filmed X-Men: First Class — not to mention
all those iffy chemicals.
She told Entertainment Weekly that she worries
about the fumes and toxins now that she's
older.
"I’m almost 25 and I’m like, ‘I can’t
even pronounce this and that’s going in
my nose?
I’m breathing that?’”
Luckily, the makeup process was cut down to
approximately three hours for Days of Future
Past and Apocalypse, thanks in part to a new
body suit they created.
That's evolution in action!
Ron Perlman
J-Law isn't the only hero who's sick of the
makeup chair.
Ron Perlman had to endure marathon sessions
for his role as Hellboy, as it took between
four and seven hours for him to get ready
every time thanks to the use of old school
prosthetics rather than CGI.
In fact, director Guillermo del Toro told
Den of Geek that Perlman's hatred of the costume
is one major reason there hasn't been a third
Hellboy film.
"He really grew tired of the makeup in the
second film and he was really rubbed the wrong
way by those seven-hour sessions."
Sounds like…hell...boy.
Ryan Reynolds
Unlike many superhero movie stars, Ryan Reynolds
didn't have to go through an arduous process
to get in costume for Green Lantern, thanks
to the fact that his suit was mostly done
with CGI.
So why does Reynolds hate the costume?
Because it looks crappy, and he loathes the
movie.
“I would, I would give it a scant…”
“...four, maybe.”
“You would give it a four?”
“Yeah a three or a four.”
“You would give it a three or four?”
“Yeah it didn’t work.”
“It didn’t work?”
“Yeah...one!
It’s a one!”
How much did he dislike his costume in the
Green Lantern?
He even made fun of it on screen in his hit
superhero parody Deadpool.
“And please don’t make the supersuit green.
Or animated!”
Paul Bettany
Back when he was providing the voice of Tony
Stark's JARVIS computer-guy in the Iron Man
films, Paul Bettany said he felt like "a pirate"
because the voiceover work was so easy it
was like stealing money.
Well, he quickly learned that he was going
to have to earn his money as The Vision, because
now that he's on screen, he has to endure
his own uncomfortable costume, which he told
USA Today takes three and a half hours to
put on.
"By the fourth and fifth day of the week,
you are really having to meditate on the line
of actors, thousands of them, who would love
to be in your position.
You have to concentrate on how lucky you are."
Christian Bale
With three Batman movies under his utility
belt, Christian Bale is something of an expert
on the importance of a comfortable costume.
After enduring a terribly constricting and
painful suit for Batman Begins, Bale requested
a new suit for The Dark Knight, resulting
in more fluid action scenes and a more relaxed
filming experience.
But his biggest piece of advice for future
Batmen, like Ben Affleck?
Make sure your batsuit has a zipper on it.
“Oh, the only thing I said to him is ‘Look,
just make sure he can take a piss without
anyone having to help him, because it’s
a little bit humiliating,’ as I went through
when you have to have somebody you know, kinda...help
you out.”
Val Kilmer
If only Christian Bale had been around to
share that bit of potty advice to Val Kilmer.
Turns out Kilmer, who played the Caped Crusader
in 1995's Batman Forever, also had major issues
with his costume, including an unfortunate
inability to use the restroom alone.
He likened wearing his suit, which took an
hour to put on, to living in an old folk's
home.
"I realized one day what wearing that suit
was like.
It was, ‘Oh!
This is what being old feels like.’
No one really listens to you any more.
You can’t really talk or hear.
You’re always falling over and someone has
to help you go to the bathroom and get dressed."
Anne Hathaway
Some superhero costumes are uncomfortable.
And then there's the signature skintight suit
and heels of Catwoman, which was even more
uncomfortable mentally than physically for
Dark Knight Rises star Anne Hathaway, as she
explained in an interview with Allure.
"[The costume] was a psychological terrorist.
The suit, thoughts of my suit, changing my
life so I would fit into that suit…It dominated
my year.
I went to the gym for ten months and didn't
come out."
Robert Downey, Jr.
As you've probably learned by now, it's tough
being a superhero, something Robert Downey,
Jr. learned the hard way when he stepped into
the role of Iron Man.
"I'd been training all these years and thought
I was pretty tough, but the first time I put
on the Mark 1 suit, I almost had a personality
meltdown.
I'm not claustrophobic, but after moving around
in it for a couple of hours, your spirit is
kind of broken and you're like, 'Okay, time
to bring in the stunt team.'"
Fortunately, these days most of the time Marvel
Studios is able to render the suit with CGI
rather than grape jelly.
“Whoo!
Hoooaaahhh!”
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!